problem 35 in the figure below every
angle is the right angle so they're just
saying you know that's a right angle
that's all right these are all right
angles right here that's right angle I
think you get the idea what is the area
what is the area in square units of the
figure so the area is how can we figure
this out so let's see we can just take
divide this up into a bunch of
rectangles and figure out their
respective areas so if we drew a
rectangle we did a rectangle right here
that rectangle what's its area is going
to be six times eight which is 48
that's that rectangle right there is 48
square units let's see what else we can
do we could do this rectangle right here
that rectangle right there it's also six
by eight so this is also going to be 48
square units right there and then we
have we do it another color we have this
rectangle that rectangle right there is
divided right that we have this
rectangle right here which is 3 by 4 so
3 times 4 is 12 units and then you have
this rectangle right here you have this
rectangle right here which is 3 by 4 so
it's also 12 square units so the whole
area of the entire thing is 12 plus 48
which is 60 right 2 plus 48 is 50 right
that's 60 so you have 60 there and then
you have another 48 which is 108 plus 12
which is 120 so the area and square
units of the figure is 120 problem 36 a
rectangular field is 363 feet long and
240 feet wide how many acres how many
acres is the field so let me draw this
field I'll do it in green because we're
talking about a field so it is it is 363
feet long and 240 feet wide that's the
dimensions of the field so if we wanted
to do it in square feet we would
multiply these two numbers so how many
square feet is it I'll do it out here
I'll do it on the left so let me
multiply it out we have 240 times 363
actually let me
I want to do it a little bit more space
so we're going to have we do it in blue
we have well maybe I should do it here
I'll do it here yeah I think it will
confuse you so I have 240 times the
three hundred and sixty three three
times zero is zero
three times four is 12 carry the one
three times two is six plus one is seven
so 720 we can ignore that for a little
bit
throw a zero down here 6 times zero is
zero 6 times 4 is 24 6 times 2 is 12
plus this 2 is 14 and then we have our
last row to deal with so we're going to
add two zeros because we're dealing with
one hundreds place three times zero is
zero
three times four is 12
okay this first one for carry the one
three times two is six plus one is seven
and now we can just add everything up 0
to 7 plus 4 is 11 carry the 1 1 plus 4
is 5 5 plus 2 is 7 and then we have 1
plus 7 is 8 so the field is 87,000
87,000 120 square feet now they they
want to know how many acres is the field
and they see an acre is 43,560 and you
see all your choices are whole numbers
and you can just eyeball this at 87,000
whatever is roughly twice 43,560 right
80,000 is roughly twice 40,000 and so
you could if you wanted to just hand
wave it you could just say well that's
just choice number a or that's just 2
right this looks like 2 times that and
if you wanted to verify it 2 times let's
let's verify it let me do it in a color
that you can actually see so 43 5 60 you
wouldn't actually have to do this on the
test but I want to show you that our
approximation works 2 times 0 is 0
2 times 6 is 12 2 times 5 is 10 plus the
1 is 11
two times three is six plus one is seven
two times four is eight
we've got the exact number which was the
square footage of the field so it's two
acres so if you do it like that
it's two acres one acre and two acre
just like that 37 the object below is
made of ten rectangular prisms that just
means these three dimensional
rectangular things each with the
dimensions of five centimeters so five
centimeters by two centimeters by five
centimeters by three centimeters by two
centimeters what is the volume in cubic
centimeters of the object so it's kind
of this plus sign or this cross looking
thing and they do this I mean these
things are everything really just to
throw you off so what is the volume of
each of these little cubes right there
so it's volume is five times two times
three so each cube has a volume of
what's five times two is 10 times 3 is
30 so each has 30 cubic centimeters
there's a darker color each of these is
30 cubic centimeters and how many of
these are there in this structure well
we have we have two layers the top layer
has one box here that's one two this is
the second box two three four and then
five so the top layer has five in this
plus sign I could draw it like this
right let me draw it like that one two
three four five so it's going to be we
have five in the top layer we have two
layers so we have ten of these boxes
right so ten boxes or rectangular prisms
if you want to call it that times 30
cubic centimeters 30 cubic centimeters
per box per box or a box the boxes
cancel out you get 10 times 30 cubic
centimeters and you get 300 cubic
centimeters is the volume of this entire
structure and that is choice D I
literally think they drew these little
diagonals just to confuse you just to
maybe make you think that you have to do
something with triangles but no you just
have to count the number of boxes and
figure out the volume of each of them
we had ten boxes each of them has a
volume of 30 cubic centimeter so 300
cubic centimeters total